band negotiator and media spokesman
sahil shaheen
and while we have a link to you it's
good to be able to use this opportunity
to talk to you straight away thank you
very much for joining us uh today sahel
shaheen and president biden said last
night if the taliban attack or personnel
or disrupt the operation that there'll
be a swift response from america and how
long are you giving him to get his
troops and his people out of the country
i think they they should
get their troops out of afghanistan
they have already
violated
the
time frame
that which was enshrined in the doha
agreement then they announced that they
will withdraw all their forces until
september 11. so they should withdraw
all their forces but
we
we are committed not to attack them and
we have not attacked them
but at some point you will want the
airport back
i would assume when are you saying that
you will take over the airport is that
september
no about the security of the airport
because there is no other force so you
know on the
the other day
people
killed because of lynching
so
in order to prevent such incidents it is
necessary that we take the shorter
security charge of the airport
so that is for the security of the
people and also
for
to organize this in a better manner
so such incident
do not happen once more
so far it has been relatively calm on
the streets of afghanistan
what
assurances can you give people that
after the u.s after the uk leave that
the taliban won't revert to the taliban
that we saw there 20 years ago
this is
a propaganda
you may have seen a lot of business
reports for the last 20
years and more than that maybe for the
last 25
years
but this is not the fact we have already
announced general amnesty to all abraham
people for all those who have worked
in the kabul administration who have
worked
with the foreigners
who are working in the embassies so we
have
announced to them that their property
will be saved
and their honor
and their life
the all those are saved and we
practically are showing by our actions
in deeds every day
so they should not be worried about that
one group of people who are worried
clearly are women whose role and
position in society in afghanistan under
the taliban was not what it is now what
we know that you've given reassurances
to women that they can continue
education um
how how much education will women be
able to have will they be able to stay
in school past the age of 12 will they
be able to go to university
yes
they tend to get education from priory
to higher education that
means university yes
this we have
announced this policy not once in
international
conferences like in the moscow
conference here in doha campus
this uh we
mentioned in our our leaders mentioned
in
their speeches
so this is our policy
and we're already working on this and
all those areas falling to us
in afghanistan there were thousands of
schools of girls schools universities
they all are operating the
schools to teach and also the students
are going to universities and even today
you may have seen the anchor of the news
and a female
she returned to her job
and so will that remain will women be
able to travel around afghanistan
without a male accompanying them and
will they be able to do so without
wearing a burqa
oh
it is a islamic hijab it is a
borka is not the only
hijab that should be observed
there is maybe a different type of hijab
so it is not limited to burka so you
will expect you will expect women to to
to wear the hijab but not necessarily
the burka
right right
what about afghan women who've been able
to wear what they would like to wear for
the last 10 years
why do you think you can dictate to them
what they can wear
so these are
not our roles these are islamic rules as
muslim women
not only in afghanistan in all islamic
countries the the women they are
observing this
hijab and all practicing women they are
observing hijab so it's a part of their
belief
so i think they will not have any
problem with that because that is a part
of the islamic rules and also the art of
islamic and abu and culture
but this basic right has access to
education and access to work that is
maintained
they can have those uh be arrived there
will be no problem in that
that it's about interpretation isn't it
and islam doesn't necessarily teach that
women have to wear the hijab
why do you think that they have to wear
it in afghanistan
and not only in the afghanistan and
honestly my islamic countries
a woman
being a muslim
she
has to according to the rules of islam
to
wear hijab
that's it maybe he's a
a female is
living in usa in european countries in
any part of the world so she has to wear
that it is not something
that we have imposed from ourselves on
women
it is something
it is
on the basis of the fully quran and the
rules of
our religion
the female
have to wear hijab that is for their
security and
okay
let's move away from that and talk about
the pledges you've made for the
leadership in afghanistan um an open
inclusive islamic government you say
what give us your vision of what that
looks like i mean could you imagine
there ever being a female prime minister
could you imagine there being female
high court judges for example
what about president karzai would there
be a role for him
about
those
when
our policy is clear which i said they
can have access to education and work
that's one thing
secondly they can hold position but that
position they can hold it in the light
of the islamic rule
so this is a general
framework for them
what about previous leaders that we've
seen over the last 10 years
president karzai
ashraf ghani could they be invited back
into afghanistan
karzai is already in kabul
sorry i just wanted to know whether you
thought president karzai could have a
role within the taliban regime
so
that's uh i i can't comment right now
but that is uh for the leadership and
the deliberation the the council
consultation that is uh going on
for formation of a new aram islamic
government so we would leave it to
to that
and in terms of the leadership i don't
have any comment
in terms of the leadership we're hearing
about that
okay in terms of leadership we're
hearing that
is traveling today from doha
to kandahar can you confirm that
it is there is intention
that
will go to
afghanistan
there's this planning but i can't say
what time exactly what time
so
maybe
um
today tomorrow
or other day i can't
say it specifically
but there is
years to go to afghanistan
and will he be leading the taliban in
afghanistan who will be leading the
taliban there
so this
under is and consultation of our thought
leadership then that decision will be
taken uh among uh
on the basis of their consultation and
deliberation that will be taken in the
year
do you have any idea how long that
consultation will take
i i think
it will be
completed soon within
two three days
so we should know who is leading the
talib taliban there in two or three days
um
in terms of the taliban's movement
through afghanistan britain and the u.s
did appear to be
very surprised at how quickly you were
able to take over
um
why do you think you face such little
resistance
because
we had the
people support
because
the kabul administration was corrupt
because those who were running
the government they there was a gap
between them their military forces
between them and the people of
afghanistan we were we are part of the
people of afghanistan
we are wearing like the people we are
thinking like the people
we are
we want what the people want
so our demands are similar our culture
are similar
our everything we are similar we are
closer to them to the people and rather
than them and they were from people who
whose females were living in other
countries
and they were just here so their purpose
was just how to line
their pockets
how to accumulate
wealth but they were not fearing for the
people so this created a huge gap
between them and the people and the
people uh
no more
trust them and even their security
forces no more trust them they the
security forces had to choice either to
support this moraband and corrupt
administration or to join us they
chose
to join us
and after that you saw falling of
districts after districts province
province after province
i think this is my observation of
what about what about those who will say
what about those who will say that the
other view is that they were just
absolutely terrified of what the taliban
were like in power before and that that
is why no resistance has been put up
because people are just too scared to
that is their narrative because always
they are not reflecting the ground
realities they are the by these
narratives
business narratives they were trying to
mislead the the world
uh opinion in their favor
but uh the the result was you know they
deceived all the world
not only themselves but all the world
to point out that the taliban were a
brutal regime is not a baseless
narrative it is simply fact
but do you think the taliban have
changed in the last 20 years
if you say that the path may be
influenced by their
reports by the propaganda in the media
for the last 20 years
you may not have been to our new years
you have not
lived in our areas but only you have
heard that is why you are saying you
will
invite you once to to our body start to
see with your with your eyes what are
happening what the people are welcoming
us
you see and just today
is
more secure cobbles it is more secure
than
happy they they shade everything has
changed there is a very secure
environment
so even when the kabul administration
set up at that time they announced that
we will arrest or tell every member of
taliban but when we got the government
we announced the general ethnicity for
all we said your proprieties here with
your honor they say your life is saved
even though we know they killed us
not
uh ten not hundreds of thousands of us
were held by them but
we still announced a general uh amnesty
this is the difference how who are the
brutal we are the brothers or they
though they who who
harassed us
who killed us who charged
tortured us we that we announced
amnesty for them so that's the
difference this something
actions not words and
the action the
sound louder than what
well it's certainly the case that that
the world will be watching the actions
of the taliban in the in the coming
weeks and days isn't it um what about
money let's talk a little bit about that
according to the world bank aid flows
have fallen
uh from around 100 of gdp into
afghanistan and in 2009 to to just over
40 percent uh late in the latest figures
it presumably means that aid is on hold
how is the taliban going to continue to
run afghanistan you're keen for the
people who work in a lot of these
organizations to go back to work to keep
the infrastructure of the country going
which is perfectly laudable but but how
are you afford to be able to do that how
would you keep it running financially
yes
when there is a peace
we have
natural resources huge natural resources
we have very hard working people
we have national businessmen
so
we will
that we will invite
investors to afghanistan
so we hope and we believe
in our people and
their capacities and their hard working
and
a good plot of planning for future that
would be
we will be able
to provide
us prosperity for our people to provide
employment for our people to
bring about
economic momentum in the country
also afghanistan is a bridge between the
central central asia and the south asia
so we work also on that to be a point of
connectivity and many other projects we
have also some mega projects like uh
this
topic pipeline
and railway
roads
projects and other projects that we hope
in our uh going to to start them
these are all big projects aren't they
how in the short term are you going to
pay people's wages though
of course we we need a cooperation of
other countries
in the short period
we need
your cooperation
in order to pay the wages of
the teachers
the officials
and uh the security of forces and also
that's the need so
we call on all countries to come to um
and
assist us i think there is a need for an
international conference
that
for
economic assistance for afghanistan as
it has been in the past i think it is
once again need of the people not for us
for the people of afghanistan there
should be an international conference of
donor countries
i mean it's going to be difficult isn't
it to convince the rest of the world to
to give money to afghanistan under the
taliban when when it was under the
taliban that al-qaeda found a home there
what reassurances can you give
president biden who's asked for them
directly that that their that your days
of hiding terrorists
in the hills in afghanistan or over that
al qaeda will not have a base in the
country under the taliban
yes this is our policy in our commitment
whether he says or not
not safe
we are following our policies and that
policy is that we will not uh allow
anyone any group individual
to use the scilab afghanistan against in
it in any country including usa
so that
we have agreed
on the basis of the doha agreement we
are abiding by that
who do you see as your closest
international ally
we have we do not have uh
allies as such and we do know we are not
member of any
bloc
military bloc but what we want that we
seek
cooperation of all countries
in the construction of afghanistan in
uh we are assisting with us in order to
provide
a proper
and dignified
life for the people of afghanistan
are you getting financial support from
countries like
pakistan russia china
no no no we do not we are not getting
support financial support but we are
having good relation with them
sorry you're getting more from these
countries
sorry if you repeat i didn't hear you
clearly yes sorry what support are you
getting from these countries
we are
getting a political support
we visited china and also russia
and
you may have seen the reports they said
the taliban are a political
and a great political and military force
of afghanistan so that is
a reality also they supported this
that's this we are getting
and and in terms of what's actually
happening on the ground today
there are people within kabul who are
keen to get to the airport there are
some reports that people have had their
passports
taken away from them or torn up at
checkpoints
what reassurances can you give to people
who want to get out of afghanistan that
they can
you know i first of all he totally
refused that the passports were taken
and then turned
and off that's not true uh these are
some of the allegations of
the last 20 years uh but
you know there were
a few people killed
during lunch lynching
in the airport and you may have seen
those
videos so because of that there is a
restriction that
such incident
does not such incident does not happen
once more so the checkpoints are
set up for that purpose
what do you think when you see the
pictures which i'm sure you must have
seen in qatar of people falling from
aeroplanes
as they take off from afghanistan from
kabul airport because they are so
desperate to leave the country
i think
that was for
the americans
and to
maintain security
not to allow all those
to enter
the airport because our forces were not
there you're not responsible
they were responsible
they it was their airplane not ours so
all those uh they belong
to them not to us
but now when we talk the security of the
airport
such incident stopped
to happen now everything is in an
orderly manner
i'm just wondering though if you you say
that while the taliban was in power that
the the atrocities that that we saw
here in the west you say that they are
propaganda that they didn't happen
if that is the case why are people so
desperate to leave the country
that they are
are taking their life into their hands
to climb onto the outside of an aircraft
while they announced that everyone
should come
and now today
because otherwise there will be no plane
and without any passport any documents
they are
will be taken to
to the western countries
and also to usa everyone wants to leave
afghanistan because afghanistan is a
poor country
so and
economically a poor country many people
are living here
up to 70 percent of the people are
living under poverty line because of the
corrupt
kabul administration so they
when they saw the unfortunately the
opportunity and uh the reports and
rumors that they should uh if they
wanted to go abroad
this is
their
chance so everyone
they are accumulated the bigger dear i
could get the beer they wanted everyone
want
so so i think the responsibility uh is
with them rest with them
not with us
yeah they did they didn't seem that that
desperate to leave before the taliban
arrived though did they um do you have a
message for the uk prime minister
yes
the yogi prime minister in all leaders
of the world they should
respect
the aspiration of the people of
afghanistan
uh you the people of afghanistan they
fought
for their freedom
with their lives
and their
equipment
and many everything they had
for the last 20 years
now they want
to open a new chapter
a new chapter of peace peacefully
coexisting
for existence
reconstruction of afghanistan so they
should respect the
aspiration and will of the people of
afghanistan and help
the people of afghanistan in
the building the country and providing
a prosperous life for the people in
economic development i think
this is their obligation because they
were
behind the destruction of that
of afghanistan during the 20
years so now
it is their
moral obligation
to also
help to the constructs afghanistan and
to help the people
to to to start
a new life
and in a new chapter of afghanistan
and in the same spirit does the taliban
promise to
respect the will the aspiration
and the freedoms of the people inside
afghanistan especially women
of course we have announced as i said
we will we
are committed to
the women
rights
through education
and also to work
to freedom of speech
in the light of our islamic rules
it is very necessary to criticize
a person on offshore if there is a need
because
if you
if you do not criticize an option
how you can reform how you can bring
about a reform so it is necessary we
believe in freedom of speech and also
the right of people
of education and work and also that all
people all citizen should be equal in
the sight of law and there should not be
any kind of discrimination that is some
of the
general principle that we believe and
also the world uh believe in that
okay will you be returning from doha
soon do you think we will be having this
conversation with you perhaps next week
from afghanistan
i hope so
yes